what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and yesterday we finally
got the full official trailer for thor
love and thunder including our first
look at christian bale as gore the god
butcher and we got an even better look
at jane foster's the mighty thor
yesterday i did a breakdown of it you
can check it out on the channel but
there was so much in this trailer that
i'm sure i'll be doing multiple videos
about it this week and the weeks to come
like for example did you notice that
when zeus flicks thor's clothes off he
has tattoos on his back now and one
tattoo that he seemingly has in
particular is a giant tattoo of loki's
horns and it says r.i.p loki above it
i'm not expecting a loki cameo in this
movie but i would sure love for him to
show up but one thing this trailer did
give us like i mentioned was a better
look at jane foster's thor but we did
not learn how exactly she becomes thor
yet and what exactly makes her worthy to
lift and willed mjolnir and how did it
get put back together well taika watiti
the director of thor ragnarok and of
course thor love and thunder has
recently come out and talked about the
story of jane foster in the mcu versus
the comics and he says that they stick
pretty true to her cancer storyline from
the mighty thor comics so we have a
little bit of an idea of what this story
is going to be like and i have a
personal theory on how i think jane
foster could have mended mjolnir became
worthy to wield mjolnir but also has
gotten cancer from it and i'll be
breaking down everything you need to
know in this video and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any future marvel
videos now if you're unfamiliar with the
story from the comics this is how jane
foster originally becomes the mighty
thor and how thor actually becomes
unworthy to lift mjolnir now i don't
believe that is going to happen in the
movie and besides he has stormbreaker at
this point so he doesn't particularly
need mjolnir but thor becoming unworthy
in the comics is a result of his
encounter with gore the god butcher who
of course is going to be the main
villain in thor love and thunder so
there is a connection there now gore the
god butcher goes around slaying gods
because he believes that gods do more
harm than good in thor's run he kills
many many gods with the all-black
necrosword and he almost kills thor but
thor defeats him however he is forever a
changed man after this in original sin
we learn how gore's beliefs affected
thor thor and the avengers then go to
the moon where they confront nick fury
where nick fury whispers a secret in
thor's ear it is later revealed that
nick fury told thor gore was right this
question leads to thor questioning
whether gods actually serve a purpose or
if they just cause more pain instead of
answering prayers for help and this lack
of faith in himself and the gods make
thor unworthy now i'm sure we'll get
some of this in thor love and thunder
gore is going to go around and he's
going to talk about his purpose and why
he hates the gods and thinks they're
useless and i'm sure thor is going to
question this just a little bit however
i think thor's had a pretty big change
of heart over the past years and he's
grown a lot and i don't think this will
make him unworthy but getting to jane in
his place jane picks up the hammer and
mjolnir deems her worthy jane knows that
there has to be a thor no matter what
there has to be somebody to protect
others it's jane's dedication to this
role that makes her worthy she knows
that other people including other heroes
like the avengers need her help so
without really questioning anything she
dives into action another trait that
makes her worthy then she encounters
thor and actually defeats him in combat
this also makes her worthy but thor also
notes that she could have used this
power for bad but instead she used it to
help others and that's kind of the main
story of jane foster she wants to help
others and that's ultimately why she is
worthy but here's the story that's going
to happen in the mcu eventually in the
comics it is revealed that jane foster
has cancer and becoming thor is kind of
a double-bladed sword here whenever she
picks up mjolnir and becomes thor all of
the cancer and toxins and basically
anything bad that is inside of her is
expunged from her body unfortunately the
chemotherapy is also expunged from her
body as well so unfortunately jane
foster being thor is what ultimately
leads her to dying and yes she does
ultimately die in the comics but even
though she's dying being thor she
chooses to be thor because she wants to
help people and that is ultimately what
makes jane foster worthy to lift mjolnir
and become the mighty thor now since
taika watiti the director said they're
going to stick pretty closely to this
story i'm assuming what i just mentioned
is pretty much going to be the story of
jane foster we know that she's going to
have cancer but it looks like she's
going to choose being thor over not
because she'll have the opportunity to
help people and if you consider all of
the events of the mcu so far that the
humans have been through on earth you
definitely know that earth needs heroes
and i think jane foster especially knows
this as good as anybody because of the
events that she went through with thor
now something that is also very
interesting in the comics is that
mjolnir actually has a mind of its own
sometimes we learned that it's an actual
entity that odin kind of trapped and
enchanted that's a whole story of its
own but basically at one point in the
comics mjolnir can kind of think for
itself and this could be another reason
why mjolnir could think that jane foster
is worthy because i'm pretty sure jane
foster is going to be the one to mend
mjolnir now if we think about the last
time that we saw mjolnir in our universe
at least not a millionaire taken from
another universe we saw our mjolnir and
thor ragnarok when hella broke it now
this spot where it was broken and hella
came back where odin died is believed to
be where new asgard is now odin told
thor asgard is not a place it's a people
asgard could be here then after the
events of avengers infinity war thor
took the remaining as guardians to that
spot and created new asgard he then
proceeded to become bro thor but all
seems to be well now but remember jane
foster is a scientist she's a world
leading astronomer but keep in mind she
also monitors energy this is how she
originally came across thor in the first
film and i'm assuming that when odin
died and heller returned there was
probably a lot of energy happening there
plus not to mention heimdall summons the
bifrost for thor and loki there there's
a good chance that jane foster saw this
and realized that it was probably thor
so there is a chance that she would have
went to that location to see what was
happening and that's where she probably
found mjolnir crumbled in pieces but
remember she's a scientist and pretty
much genius so from here i believe that
she collected all of the pieces of
mjolnir took it back to a lab and tried
to put it back together now throughout
the mcu we learned a little bit about
jane's career in thor 1 thor the dark
world in avengers 1 colson tells thor
that they hooked jane up with a pretty
sweet gig that had handsome pay then in
avengers age of ultron where thor and
tony stark are bragging about their
women thor says that jane might get a
nobel prize so i'm thinking that jane
probably has the smarts and the means
meaning all the equipment to mend
mjolnir and i think that this might
actually be a part of her being worthy
enough to lift mjolnir because like i
said mjolnir sometimes kind of has a
mind of its own and mjolnir might deem
jane worthy because she's the one that
would repair mjolnir but a big question
right now is how exactly does jane
foster get cancer and could it be
mjolnir that actually gives her cancer
now there's a lot of people theorizing
that the hammer could actually have some
type of radioactive properties to it
after all it is an alien metal also not
to mention when thor is talking about
building stormbreaker he basically tells
the guardians that stormbreaker would
kill them if they ever tried to wield it
so clearly uru metal isn't something
really meant for humans to come in
contact with so it is definitely
possible that while jane is actually
trying to reconstruct the hammer it in
turn actually gives her cancer this
would kind of fall in line with how her
story goes in the comics but not exactly
be page for paige jane knows that thor
is a hero in that he protects earth and
he protects asgard and the other realms
as well so she would know that he would
need mjolnir to continue to do that and
despite the properties of uru metal
maybe being dangerous to her she decides
to try and fix it anyways because thor
needs his hammer and that in turn would
make her worthy enough to lift mjolnir
transforming her into the mighty thor
that we're going to see in thor love and
thunder let me know what you think about
this theory in the comments down below
do you think that this is what's going
to happen in thor love and thunder or do
you have a different theory of your own
be sure to let me know in the comments
and don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest marvel news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof